secretary of state is in Turkey where
he's been meeting the Turkish foreign
minister let's go to his name called
solu who's in Ankara where the meeting
has been taken place so what have the
Secretary of State and the foreign
minister had to say in their address to
the media which has just finished
well actually this is the first official
visit paid by U.S Secretary of State
Antonio blinken since he resumed office
two years ago and yesterday he visited
the earthquake at areas with his Turkish
counterpart Melissa and today they held
bilateral meetings interdelegations
meeting in Lincoln is expected to also
be received by the Turkish president and
now they are leaving the presidential
Hall where the press conference happened
but today's agenda was mostly about
bilateral relations and the the regional
issues that two countries to a
long-standing allies are cooperating on
Anthony blinken suggested that his
country is now pledging one billion
dollars extra and then he mentioned that
the United States is withstanding with
its long-standing Ally turkey but of
course there are other issues that they
have discussed like the war in Ukraine
like the developments in Syria and and
trickiest
acquisition request for F-16 just as a
tricky about Russian missile defense
system in 2019 Ankara was kicked out of
an F-35 fighter Jack project which
turquoia was a strong partner of so now
turkey is trying to buy f-16s but the
U.S Congress hasn't approved it yet
Turkish foreign minister mentioned about
this but both top diplomats underlined
their cooperation will last and of
course they have discussed the NATO bid
for Sweden and Finland and turkey said
they are evaluating the process for two
Nordic countries separately but they
showed solidarity and support the true
care
live for us there thank you